das hier ist jetzt eindeutig eine
kräftig table und zwei höfen in den
justizkreisen dritten war gott du hast
einfach mal die basis geplündert oh mein
gott ich darf das er mit leben oder
sterben dürfen natürlich 48
[Musik]
wunderschönen guten tag und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge von
minecraft war mit dem konto nur noch
vier fleisch das ist dass gutes tut ich
bin schon gesagt dass du dass du stirbst
es wird nacht das ist das ist ich weiß
jetzt nicht ob ich hier also ich kann
natürlich auch in der höhle bleiben aber
dies auch jetzt gar nicht so gut
ausgeleuchtet ich komm mal hoch okay ich
komme halt ich guck mal ich hab mal nach
oben gelegen kommen mir entgegen ich
komm ich kommt ihr entgegen meinen mein
mann mein kleiner freund wenn ich die
anderen tun es doch gar nicht befolgt
ich muss erstmal gucken wo ich hier
überhaupt dann muss ich hab' ich muss
hier irgendwie war ich muss ja nicht mal
irgendwie irgendwo mehr abbauen
das ist echt dass er angeschrieben fall
es ist jeden fall abbauen alter das so
also ja ich muss würde ich muss mal
richtig machst abbauen
das verschwinden wieder so viel zeit am
anfang der episode das ist also das ist
die die die konsole
so jetzt bin ich hier hallo ich bin
gerade in diesem vierten wald in dem wir
am anfang waren ja jetzt schon wieder
vieles schweine also ich habe auch
skelette ist eine familie da
ich will jetzt einfach mal sonst könnte
ich gucke ich bekomme jetzt aber hier
nicht leicht nicht zu weit mit 23 und
ich habe ein herz verloren hast du
probleme sich einfach nichts kannst ja
das ist richtig geil mit seinem schwert
wir brauchen auf jeden fall bücherregal
aber ich finde einfach es kann sein dass
jeder einfach schon zuckerrohr
mitgenommen hat das kann ja sein dass
ich habe hier noch 40 kann das nicht
auch an bauen einfach das ja-wort lukas
ist natürlich aber du solltest das ja
auch machen
zehn millionen creeper entgegen das ist
unglaublich der skelette ist schießen
wir auch noch hinterher
wenn steuer das ist ja also dass das
gerede dass machen so das kann ich mir
auch einen bogen macht na ja ich weiß wo
ich bin dann bin ich mal übrigens die
tür zu öffnen sagt ist nun kommen sie
mal rein
die unsere tür in anführungszeichen hier
ist essen essen ihm gestern ihr gehen
[Musik]
die fein darin tut mir leid die
britische version aus versehen
ausgewählt du bist das ist ein krieg
scream peinlich es ist nicht zu fassen
und verzaubert immer einen bogen
exponierter gleich mit infinity ward und
bogen macht so oder so es ist auf jeden
fall anders als du denkst immer er jetzt
da ausgeleuchtete höhle
ich ging das denn nochmal sich gleich
wieder darin muss ich gleich wieder so
war es ja natürlich
so jetzt mal gucken wie viele dann
infiniti konnte doch einfach eine party
ist was ist das stärker als habe ich
allen einen bogen mit stärke 1 9 das ist
doch ist ich habe jetzt einfach mal war
einmal mitgenommen haben was haben wir
da ja schon oben ist infiniti dazu ich
habe ein bogen mit stärke weil infiniti
ist eine der fortgeschrittenen
verzauberung ja der heftigkeit ja
natürlich wm findet heftig geilich was
er so macht man doch pfeile oder weil
das wird nicht mit federn federn ich
will auch gleich mit feder mit feder
stick und flint ach so flynn muss auch
noch rein kubala hatte jetzt da jetzt
wieder die infos hier
der us maler die alte vix kanüle ja bei
uns ist einfach sonnen- wasser-
wasserfall vom berg runter ist
eigentlich richtig schön aus worin wir
sind was du siehst auch richtig schön
aus
trotz dafür auf einmal alter gerade wenn
du nackt auf dem bett liegt conny gerade
aber nur wenn ich gerade da möchte ich
in deine socken sprit spritzen ich nicht
sagen springen wollte ich sagen so ein
ekelhafter perversling das ist nicht zu
fassen mit dir jetzt mal hier ich hatte
doch noch irgendwo echt traurig dass ja
irgendwo ist wir haben ja noch 28 rohes
rindfleisch das thema beraten
es ist ganz viel was gebraten wird im
ofen ja für die ich mir noch einkommens
gibt es was zu essen
es ist also nicht so wie im echten leben
da muss ich mich selbst auf essen
deswegen hab ich ja noch ein abend der
andere gab es gestern rest sollte man
auch mal dass sich reisen aber auch
heftig geil
ja ich hab ich habe schon ein gemacht
aber jetzt muss ich einfach wieder
selbst tun kann man nun konnte ich kann
nicht ich kann ich kann nicht mehr
hallo hallo du willst du verzog auge
geholt
ok hast du hier und irgendwie erden das
waren einfach anbauen komm doch mit
doch mein kleiner freund du bist du
weißt was heute los war bin ich um die
viel zu freundlich wo bist du da unten
warum sitzen du warum denn
guck mal was ich mache das geht garnicht
knochenmehl jetzt sage ich wäre es gilt
du da los bei dir ist die ich einfach
nicht ich habe da ich habe da unten das
angebot aber es ist auch eigentlich dumm
das stimmt deswegen dass das mal ach da
um nachher ich ja gut ich dachte ich
komme ich komme wieder nach oben das war
gar nicht so sinnvoll was ich getan ab
es war einfach nicht sind jetzt mal was
ich hier vor habe was ich getan habe ich
komme zu dir machen wir mal wieder ein
spektakel das war super nett von dir
aber selbstverständlich mache ich den
reisekoffer der conti der links von
seiner mama damals noch ein bisschen
manieren gelernt bevor sie die ganze
familie verlassen hat jetzt mache ich
wenn ich bitte um entschuldigung dass
ich vergess ich vergesse dass immer dass
das wieder informations in lahde
ich bin ja das ganze ganz schön direkt
so jetzt warum hab ich nach rugby macht
egal ob schmal gewordene hacker ja es
ist ganz gut ich bin jetzt hab ich ja
bitte die ist für dich kein freund warum
andauernd mein freund ist hat er mit der
hacke jetzt geht das doch hier mal
gehalten geekelt da ich hier gemeinde
runde
da wir ein tolles fällt was wir gleich
wieder vorne am ende der folge so und
das wird als drauf machen das oder wie
du brauchst du brauchst kein feld auch
wenn jetzt kann hätte ich mein ding
suite ich habe ja ein bisschen hirn
erscheint richtiges mal wieder damit
deine augen rot werden ja du klingst du
klingst hat aber dann verbindung ist
gerade ganz schön ganz schön gestorben
für momente
ja er wächst eigentlich nur auf sand was
du zucchero also zog ich weiß gar nicht
wo genau ich kann das auch mal wieder
unten einem bach ran und vielleicht ist
es ja irgendwann oder sehen wir das
einfach so mitnehmen was sagst du mir so
was machen ich brauche ja jemand macht
du das mal mit den mit den büchern hier
ist zuckerrohr bitteschön in berlin ich
gehe weil er diamanten suchen ja das
kannst du das dass das kann ich das ist
mein das meinen job ich brauche doch
nicht mal hier wachsen die dann auch auf
erde oder nur ich weiß gar nicht ich
glaube die wachsen wirklich nur auf sand
oder du glaubst das coni connect ein
kanal hat minecraft und titel also dass
das erhält das erwarte jetzt wo ich weiß
es nicht ich weiß dass so eine komische
app
ja aber da steht stehen nun kräftig
konzept überzeugt das ist nichts
sinnvolles drin darf man verdammt warum
macht man so eine app dann hole ich mal
einfach sand aber ein bisschen essen war
schon geil
ich habe gar nicht das habe ich zur
folge sagt gucken dürfen da braten 23.6
schön gesagt ich hab' ich habe mich
vorbereitet da habe ich meinen kleinen
koch wortgewalt bild
aber es ist auch irgendwie
also hinter uns ist auch keiner her also
so wen er töten möchte ja ich glaube
darauf warum habe ich warum warum das
ist im koma foto oh jetzt hab ich drauf
steht soll ist gestorben
naja ich hab ich habe mir das erste mal
eine kräftig table in diesem projekt
gemacht
sie ist ich war bisher sehr produktiv
ich habe jetzt ja da ja doch eher und
technischen fortschritt wenn ich sinnlos
mit den kilos
ich sehe es ja einen nach dem anderen
rockig weg kann ich das nicht auch
irgendwie mit jörg pilawa blubbern
ich hab irgendwie zwei teile ich habe 14
uhr 15 also im köcher
ich dachte schon ich hätte wieder der
mann aber das war er braucht den smaragd
was braucht man das überhaupt nicht weil
ich hab noch nie das macht genutzte
minecraft noch nie
du kannst dich aber wenn ich mein dorf
glaube ich ja deswegen ist das ja
irgendwie kommt komplett wo ist
eigentlich sagen mädchen das weiß ich
nicht ich hab es definitiv millionen
gebracht
dann habe ich gesagt hab ich dich nicht
ich war aber brav und ups gestreichelt
vielleicht auch ein bisschen viel jeder
wieder was könnte mit jeder machen mit
leder brauchst du für die bücher wir
brauchen leder für für bücher bücher
bestehen aus drei papier und einem einem
leder gemacht haben sie ja ich hab hier
hatten gefunden das main event center
ist das ist einfach gut sind sogar ich
guck mal wie viele das sind gerade sind
sechs stück schon gedacht ja geil das
ist dann läuft nach egal ich gucke 3
danach zuckerrohr bei einer anderen
richtung
mach es erlaubt ja ja ich erlebte das
nicht einmal diese 720 6 mitgenommen
aber da ist noch genug drin so leute
moment ich leuchte aus damit ihr euren
augen ein bisschen was erkennen könnt in
meinen videos also dass ich die richtig
krass wie sie sind wir hier nicht
gelaufen das ist viel schöner hier ja
allgemein ist die welt ganz cool finde
ich also schade dass sie alle anderen
überlassen werden weil er wie er sagt
wir sollten keine motto machen
dazu sind wir nicht überheblich sein ja
das ist natürlich natürlich es ist ja
also schön ist gutes equipment ist ja
schön und gut und es sollte bei uns auch
nicht schlechter band beiden armen
leuten in der hand ist ein richtiger
sich drinks und und wenn hier sind halt
so falschen leute beim beim pvp halt
verkackt dann ist es also ja wie gesagt
wenn wir auch so eintreffen
gibt die dreadlocks in den harz das
kannst du auch dann überhaupt sagen ist
egal
ja ich eigentlich ist völlig wurscht
ich hab das komischste komisches tritt
mining system der welt
normalerweise gebe da viel viel
strukturiert davor aber was wollte ich
zu sagen wolltest du jetzt
liebeserklärung machen
das habe ich nicht aber gerade nicht
getraut und dann siehst du mich einfach
nicht vergessen
ich wollte etwas wichtiges auch noch
sagen ja ich habe auch zettel moment
überfielen stil essen
ich schreibe wirklich zettel ich bin so
in dem projekt drinnen ich habe vor mir
drei zentrum legen die nur die das auf
das projekt beziehen
aber ich glaube ich glaub ich hab alles
abgehakt schon in der letzten episode
was ich machen wollte schon einmal aufs
mittelmeer weil man findet hier auch
einfach keine sachen also ich jetzt ein
richtig geiler dschungel gerade aber das
bringt mir egal ich brauche ja sogar
krieg kann ich irgendwie anders bücherei
nicht mit langen zweite rezept für alles
glaubt diese ganze ist das in darauf
hier ist der pilz votings darunter sind
sicherlich ist einfach aber jetzt
einfach an apples aber ich nehme trotz
mittlerweile kommen so viele pilze
hausach so dass solche die gerade an dem
alle roten pilze mit nem alle pilze mit
weil wir dann uns pilze machen
ich weiß aber dass ich natürlich dass
ich unten drunter bin da wachsen keine
pilze wenn du draußen rum läuft nimmt es
mit einem alles mit alle pilze damit
keiner darf hin zum hat ich habe den
ganzen kampf endete ich bin am ende der
arena ich glaube ich glaube so und 90
prozent von allem was ihr unter der erde
ausgehöhlt wurde das war sowieso wie ich
bin hier so oder so berger weiter vom
dienst jedoch ich habe wieder habe ich
dennoch 18 pilze ist egal ich habe 18
roten richtig dass ich keine pilze und
18 18 roten pilz 18 brauner das hat
schon mal 18
das ist ja der arena das ist gut das ist
das ist schön konnte ich bin kann hughes
und stolz und alles mit grandios
gerade hier los ich bin also ich bin
einfach grandios conny so fackel
bitteschön damit ein bisschen was sehen
könnt ja ich habe nur noch mal
ich bin ich bestimmt so nett die user
die ich schon geht das ganze vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr ausreicht
youtube ich dachte dass ich jetzt einen
namen gesehen da ist niemand auf dem
server ja das habe ich mit dem stand
auch schon gedacht dass wenn du nach
rennende war ein plätze nehmen zwar noch
wasser wasser ist ja ok was also kann
auch gefährlich sein kann sein
trinkwasser kann auch gefährlich sein
conti hat eine ganz starke wasser
allergie ja ich tue ich mich auch nie
wasser allagui ich mich deswegen sieht
auch so aus eigentlich wie dem aus in
der session bin ich aber auch irgendwie
echt ein bisschen auf gewalt gewisses
tut mir leid conny das hast du nicht
verdient wenn wir das alles zu herzen
ja ich glaube ich denke also dass ich da
bin wo glp und zombie sich unter anderen
die pilze gegraben haben aber es hat
eigentlich ein roter pilz und links
davon ist die basis von glp und zombie
nächstes die basis genau links davon
einfach rheingraben einfach rein fit mit
guter junge ja ok gucke ich mir schon
wieder komisch der kommissar
unnützes zeug ich einfach aber es ist
einfach nicht es ist es ist unglaublich
wie wenig zuckerrohr sie gibt ja das ist
wahrscheinlich haben ja alle irgendwie
früher dran gedacht und die besten und
so war aber sonst bin ich einfach mit
mit mit knochenmehl so ein bisschen
pushen das habe ich schon viele sind
diesmal sind keine diamanten es ist ein
krieg der aber gerade ist das ganz gut
aber ich bin eindeutig in der höhe von
von jemand anderem
ich bin ich bin eindeutig weil hier sind
schon fackeln gesetz ich glaube das
könnte das sein wo wo simon und und und
tadel sind ja dann gehe aber nicht an
die projekte von denen schreibt einfach
mal so ein trauriges schilter dran
ich gucke hatte ich gucke ich weiß jetzt
habe ich halt bange wenn da jetzt jemand
scheint es hier ist ja hier ist
eindeutig eine kräftige table und zwei
höfen
du hast einfach mal die basis geplündert
oh mein gott ich darf das er mit leben
oder ich denke wenn er natürlich 48
eisen ist nicht das ist eindeutig die
basis von simon hatte also leute jetzt
ganz zur erklärung das riesenprojekt
konform das ist nicht böse oder sonst
was man da mitnehmen
rein aus dem grund weil also man darf
nur nicht aus der projekten system das
würden die bei uns aufmachen also bitte
jetzt hier nicht irgendwie anfang durch
die gegend zu reden ohne ende ist ja
nicht böse gemeint aber 48 eisen sie
bald schon ist die nummer übel alter
schrill annette schild dran am besten
ich schreibe ich was so 70 gezeigt wird
die unproduktiven ja gezeichnet die die
unproduktiven eurobahn ist das böse das
tut mir jetzt echt ein bisschen leid
aber dem projekt musste als knallhart
sein alter können kann man jetzt nicht
so wenn ich glaube ich werde ja schon
wieder alle schreiben darunter das ist
voll gemein
aber das ist ja ja klar es ist es ist
konform regelkonform was wir gesagt was
ich weiß jetzt auch schon dass das euch
dass das euch das aufregend wird das ist
nicht schön das schild aber egal wie
mache ich das am besten leute ich weiß
auch dass wir durch das würde ich
bestimmt aufregend so weiter und so fort
und wurde dem krieg nicht darauf
gekommen dass hier noch sieben
zuckerrohr sind 8 der ist einfach da
lang gelaufen dann habe ich den boxen
mit verfahren wurde auf einer stadt
nicht vor 8 zuckerrohr krasse ich denke
alles ist mittlerweile so ein bisschen
auf unserer seite so zac also hin und
meinte gerade in unserer confiseur jahr
wir haben zuschauer geschrieben wir
wollten portal machen uns oder wir haben
in der gleichen frage noch gesagt dass
jetzt nicht wollen ein bisschen so wie
hier durch das nicht und jetzt gehört
einfach seine basis mensch ich war ich
weiß nicht ob es sein ist aber ich
glaube es ist seine bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass ich noch den eingang schöne
dazu so dass auch die möglich nicht in
diese möglichen diese richtungen gelockt
werden
ja also nochmal und nochmal hier
wirklich zur anmerkung natürlich mache
das nicht weil ich mega sie sein will
oder weiter wir müssen also die folge
werden ist das 16 02 16 minuten 20 okay
jetzt raus ich eigentlich in der
nächsten folge wiener dann ziehen wir
oben und dann reden wir weiter lassen
ihr werdet euch gefallen hat und
justieren